welcome to the 10-year anniversary of
the science Asylum this is
wild I
I can't believe it's been this long
um but
before we get started I'm going to look
at the chat here in a second but before
we get started just so you know uh I
know some people in previous streams
have complained that like the live chat
replay
disappears uh and so I've got oh it's
over here it's first uh I've got the
chat up on the screen so we should be
able to
to see it regardless of any glitches
happened on YouTube so
awesome all right
let's see what we got here I think we
got some pretty good questions
already we're gonna have some fun with
these uh people have certainly taken the
ask me anything to Heart
uh let's start with
looks like Nerf walls
I don't even know if you're still here
um but he said what exactly is
renormalization and why is quantum
gravity hard um Okay so
I'm not sure how related these two
things are but
renormalization is kind of a a math
trick in Quantum field Theory which is a
video I just put out
um but basically
when we actually do the math raw I guess
would be a good word for it
it doesn't things don't work out the way
they should we don't get results that we
necessarily expect
um and so we kind of
renormalization is kind of a
mathematical trick to kind of like force
things
to be
the way they should be you know by like
some kind of like force plugging in
numbers that we know to be true that
we've measured like the charge on an
electron and stuff like that
and so uh that's that's about the best I
can do with that without doing a whole
video on it but basically it's a uh
a math trick that we kind of put on top
of uh
on top of quantum field Theory Quantum
electrodynamics to be specific uh to
deal with some things that we
shouldn't be getting
some results some predictions that we
shouldn't be getting now why quantum
gravity is hard this is a video this is
a video I want to make for sure but
there's a few reasons
the first reason I think that the the
biggest reason is that
the way that usually quantum gravity is
something we can
it's about bringing gravity or general
general relativity into Quantum field
Theory
uh but the problem is quantum fields are
defined at points in space and time
right it's defined using space time
and if you want to have a model of
quantum gravity then all of a sudden you
have to take
space-time itself and you have to turn
it into just another field another
quantum field and when you do that you
now have all the other Quantum Fields
defined in terms of this one that's
somehow special and so like things
it it's
sort of a a conceptual hurdle I guess
that we have to overcome and I mean I
say conceptual as if like
it's it's a problem we just have to
overcome you know intellectually which
it's
it's a fundamental math that presents a
fundamental mathematical problem and
it's a big problem because people have
been working on it for decades and
haven't been able to solve it so
um
that's that's sort of the the quickie
answer
uh let's see
uh
got some questions let's see questions
germond
can anti-matter exist in a parallel
universe or plane of existence next to
that which the physical Universe exists
in and if so could these two planes
interact outside the realm of
annihilation uh well okay so
anti-matter does not exist in a parallel
realm and as far as we know no parallel
Realms or parallel parallel universes
actually do exist we don't actually know
that uh and it's a pretty common
practice that if we can't show that
something exists we should assume that
it doesn't
uh until proven otherwise so
we're going to assume that parallel
universes don't exist because we have
zero evidence for their existence
uh and as for anti-matter anti-matter is
just a different kind of matter that
exists in our own Universe it doesn't
need a parallel universe to exist
uh and anti-matter Annihilation is just
how those things interact right they
tend to be opposites in basically every
way and so when they come into contact
they cancel out and then they're energy
can't be Mis destroyed so it has to go
somewhere
uh and that usually goes into another
field like if an electron and a positron
annihilate that energy goes into the
photon field and two photons are created
two photons
um all right
active chat uh thanks Michaela for the
Super Chat
um
Sean Ewing says uh in several other
videos you say that energy can't exist
on its own only as a property of
something else yes that's I still stand
by that
it's always some number that we assign
to things like particles
or fields in the case of quantum fields
and the question is you also say photons
are pure energy now I I don't remember
ever saying that but that is something
that is commonly said so it's possible I
might have said that in some of my
earlier content you know before I
started leaning into Nuance
um but
it
when when physicists try to explain
things and they say oh well matter and
antimatter annihilate each other
um
they they create Pure Energy but they
don't they don't create pure energy they
create two photons they create other
particles that carry that energy just
like the electrons and the electron and
positron carry that energy so
it's definitely a property you don't
have to there's nothing to reconcile
there uh it's just saying that photons
are pure energy is just
bad language
it's it's not necessarily wrong I mean
but it's it's essentially how we Define
things I guess but
um it's it lacks nuance
foreign
Moreno Hernandez what is the what does
permeability and permeativity of free
space mean
uh well okay so those are just constants
uh they're sort of the uh they're bad
names they kind of have a historical
origin
uh back when we sort of imagined that
everything was a fluid during the 1800s
we we kind of wanted to imagine that
everything was a fluid it was sort of a
big sort of like scientific Paradigm
that we had
um and so
those words come from that
that mentality that everything was fluid
right we wanted to imagine that like
electricity was a fluid hence why we
call it an electric current right we
wanted to imagine that heat was a fluid
which is where the word calorie comes
from the fluid that represented heat the
heat fluid was called caloric
and so we still have this unit of energy
that was
uh that kind of sticks around from that
and the words permeability and
permeativity are just fancy like fluid
words
it's their their words about like fluids
passing through things right
um and so that's don't read too much
into those words there's just it's just
a historical tradition it's not they
don't really have a place
in the language anymore just kind of
think of it as like the electric
constant and the Magnetic constant I
wouldn't
I wouldn't think of it any any other way
uh all right
oh got several super chats here
um
so yeah let's start with uh let's do
Michaela here
what's the mathematical difference
between the EM field and classical
electrodynamics and the EM field and QED
this is a great question uh it comes
down to language again like there's a
lot of things in physics that come down
to language but
I think that
the
the problem here is that
and this is why when I do Quantum field
Theory videos I refer to the EM field in
Quantum field Theory I refer to it as
the photon field because that's the
particle that's in it and that's the
name we give to all the other fields we
if it has electrons in it we call it the
electron field and so I try to call it
the photon field there to sort of
distinguish
uh but a lot of people call it the EM
field just out of habit I guess
there really isn't
a whole lot of overlap I mean the the
predictions that the photon field or em
field and QED
uh has the predictions have to be
consistent with classical
you know models of light
but
it
I I I wouldn't really look for an
overlap there in in Quantum field Theory
it behaves just like any other Quantum
field it just has the photon field just
has some very specific properties that
make it the photon field
there really isn't anything special
about it in that way
whereas the EM field in classical
physics and like from the 1800s you know
we're talking like Maxwell and heavy
side and stuff
1885-ish
that stuff is
it was special it was a special thing
that we found
uh and then it you know later on when we
learned about quantum mechanics and
stuff it became less and less special
uh but as far as a mathematical
difference I mean we treat them very
differently I mean they're both fields
but that's about as far as the
similarities go everything else is
essentially different
um
the universe is it infinite or finite
well uh that depends
the observable universe is definitely
finite uh but then there's a larger
entire universe
that may or may not be infinite it might
be finite we're not sure
uh but we can take
we can take measurements of things like
overall like Cosmic curvature in our own
observable universe and the part that we
can see
and based on that we have a lower Bound
for the size of the entire universe we
know it's at least 20 times larger than
the part we can see
but we don't know exactly how big it is
uh and we we kind of assume it's
infinite because it's kind of weird for
a value like curvature to be so close to
zero and not actually be zero
um and if it's zero if it's exactly zero
then we know that the entire universe is
infinite uh if it's not zero then
it could go either way uh but
it'd be kind of weird for it to be that
close to zero and not actually be zero
and so we kind of assume it is zero
exactly and we assume it's infinite uh
it doesn't really if whether or not that
is you know that assumption doesn't
really affect anything we do
um it's just the easier option and it
raises fewer questions but we don't
actually know
for sure
how big the entire universe is
we just know it's bigger than the part
we can see by a lot
uh
what is your favorite dinosaur a
Triceratops always has been always will
be
uh could a neutrino Collide With A
Strange Matter triggering a doomsday
switch uh
you know
I'd like to say something here but I
don't actually know enough I don't think
I know enough about Strange Matter
to say to answer this question
specifically
um Strange Matter is just matter made
out of like mostly strange quarks uh and
it's speculated that maybe we can find
that inside in the cores of neutron
stars but uh that's about all I know
about it
uh my my specialty going through grad
school was white dwarfs not
neutron stars and so uh and inside white
dwarfs is just regular you know matter I
mean it's degenerate matter but that's
that's a whole other conversation but
it's not it's not strange matter
uh and so I don't actually know a lot
about that
um
uh live Edwards thank you for the
Super Chat uh it says
um the question is it easier to thread a
wet spaghetti noodle through a straw
or is it easier to reset your two-factor
authentication credentials
um it's rhetorical
I don't actually know I don't have a
Bitcoin account so
um I never really got into the whole
cryptocurrency scene
and so I don't actually I mean I realize
it's a rhetorical question but
uh I don't actually
wet spaghetti though I don't if
anybody's ever handled what's spaghetti
that's not
not easy to deal with
um
oh got another got a couple other super
chats here
uh
among once
once107.com five dollars thank you
uh
do you have a take on what brings about
consciousness
uh I mean that's all it would be would
be a take because we don't nobody knows
exactly
what Consciousness is or where it comes
from
um my personal opinion is that
uh well you see here is it is a large
system of complex interactions like the
human brain um yeah so I think I think
that
Consciousness is something that arises
from complexity it emerges from it it's
an emergent property of something
complex like a brain
um and so I I don't think that I think
that's what makes it it's part of what
makes it difficult to study right it
isn't like we can look into the brain
and we can be like this is the spot this
spot is what causes Consciousness it's
kind of the the whole thing together
and and that makes it difficult because
there's a lot of things going on in the
brain and I know
neuroscientists are they're working on
it but uh they're a long way from an
answer I think
uh
let's see here it does science see any
possibility regarding afterlife or
reincarnations uh as far as I know
science hasn't said anything about that
uh it doesn't appear to be anything we
can observe or take measurements of and
so uh science can't really say anything
about it
uh what if say a photon actually hits
the nucleus and not the electron
I'm sure that happens all the time that
that's not uh all that weird right
photons could possibly I mean it doesn't
happen that often but it photons can hit
nuclei like that's not weird that
happens and then the energy you'll just
it'll either pass through or it'll get
absorbed by one of the quarks or
something
um
quarks do interact with the
electromagnetic field and so they can
uh they can't absorb photons that is a
thing that happens
uh and nothing all that weird would
happen
you
uh so the EM field and QED isn't
obtained by quantizing the classical em
field uh
[Music]
I would say no I mean you can you can
quantize the electromagnetic field in
regular old quantum mechanics that is a
thing that
is done it's kind of like attack on
correction term that we add when we're
studying things like atoms
uh it's not the same thing I mean we
kind of when we did that it kind of led
us down a road that eventually got us to
Quantum electrodynamics to Quantum field
Theory
but I wouldn't say that the photon field
itself is a quantized electromagnetic
field
but then I could be working with the
definition of quantize that maybe
isn't uh the standard
uh see
Noble Watcher thank you for the the
super chats uh how
let's see explain how 1s orbitals don't
crash in the nucleus uh I mean it
sometimes they do
uh there is a non-zero chance of the
electron being inside the nucleus and
that can cause problems
it it's it's non-zero it's very small
but it's non-zero and then at which
point you know it might
interact with a proton and and turn the
proton into into a neutron and it would
like change the nucleus a little bit and
turn the whole thing into
um I wouldn't turn it into an ion it
would just change the element that is
present that is a thing that
that that happens
um and so I guess how does it not crash
into the nucleus well sometimes it does
uh but remember this is all quantum
mechanics and it's all probabilistic so
uh Rose Thorne our Feynman diagrams
literal uh no
I would say definitely not
the Fineman diagrams involve a lot of
things like virtual particles that don't
really exist and
we know they don't exist because one
they don't always work and two uh we
have a way of treating Quantum Fields by
leaving them Quantum fields we don't
have to pretend like the field is a
clump of particles in order to make it
work that's easier when it works but it
is not
it is not something we have to do
and so
I would I I would say no there are other
there are other options
foreign
what do you enjoy when you're not doing
YouTube I normally play video games
mostly retro type games my wife and I
play a lot of uh Lego games on the
switch those are some of the newer ones
we do
but
uh as far as like stuff I do games I
play by myself it's usually like older
stuff like uh Nintendo 64 and earlier
I was getting a bit
uh too busy with like early adult things
when GameCube came out and so I never
really I never had it
uh and so mostly like
you know Nostalgia things for me but
it's it's video games
it's kind of a way to occupy my brain
and get it off of other stuff
see this account is pending review a
nice username
um thanks for the super chat but this
account is pending review wants to know
uh black holes are the cores of galaxies
most of them
uh I propose that galaxies are bound
together by Einstein rosenbridges
I mean you can certainly speculate that
we haven't found any evidence to suggest
that
and the thing is like an Einstein
rosenbridge the way that it works it
would have like
a black hole on one side and a white
hole on the other maybe and at which
point
um I mean there's other there's other
types of wormholes but basically
if it's a black hole and it is a doorway
to something else that's something else
is usually a white hole and it's it's in
a different Universe right so not only
do you have to assume white holes exist
you also have to assume that other
universes exists for that to make sense
and that only works assuming that we
completely understand what's happening
inside black holes and we don't we don't
have any confirmation at least
um I suppose it's possible but uh it's
not anything we'd ever be able to like
confirm
let's see I think I lost
a spot here all right
translate a little bit
nope don't have
a translation for that
uh
Karina's ditties uh thank you for the
five dollar Super Chat
uh I'm not sure what you're asking I
tried to do a translation of it in
Google Translate and it did not
cooperate so
um
hopefully you can translate for me and
ask again uh
see
uh
got some good questions in here
how many atoms are in front of your or
my nose I honestly have no idea
um a lot quite a bit but but I I I would
have to sit down and really think about
how to do the calculation
uh
could AI teach physics better for intro
courses
uh I don't think so I mean see this is
the problem with AI teachers I mean
you'll get they'll be able to give you
knowledge right but there is this
there's this connection you get in a
student-teacher relationship that you
just
wouldn't get with at least current day
AIS Uh current AIS aren't like
um agis AGI is a an artificial general
intelligence that would be something
that you know people are afraid of like
you know Skynet or whatever from
Terminator but
um the AIS now they they are designed or
trained to perform a very specific task
and everyone's kind of freaked out
because things like chat GPT have a like
a language model and now you can just
talk to it which you know is a huge
Improvement but it's still not like
thinking
like a human thinks as far as we know I
guess but uh it doesn't seem to be that
way because of how they're built the way
they're built it doesn't it's just
guessing a word at a time
um and so I would say no they they might
be able to teach physics but they they
can't teach it better than a person at
least not yet
laughs
uh smokestack thank you for the what is
that pounds five pounds
um
thank you for the Super Chat uh says as
Beetlejuice Beth Hill jawsa if we want
to be specific
um I bet I think that's how you
pronounce it uh has gone Supernova will
we see it with the naked eye in our
lifetime I mean assuming it has I mean I
don't know we we don't know we don't
know if it's gone Supernova until we see
it I mean but technically
uh our neutrino detectors would flare up
and
we would
we would see a bunch of new detections
an abnormally large amount of detections
before
you know before that happened and based
on how many extra detections we were we
were measuring we could determine
whether or not it was a problem with our
own sun or uh a nearby star uh in this
case uh uh Beetlejuice as it's usually
called
uh if that has gone Supernova like a day
or so before we actually see the bright
light we'd see a flush of neutrinos the
neutrinos come out before the Supernova
actually happens so
uh we'll see that first and so we'll be
able to know and like pay attention to
it
um
I don't think it going Supernova would
like be an Extinction event
um but I think that it would be bright
enough that you could probably get
sunburn from it
uh Beetlejuice burn I guess you'd call
it at that point but uh I don't think
it's close enough to do any like major
damage
uh Crouching Tiger Hidden atom wow I
haven't seen you in a long time uh
thanks for the super chat but you're
asking can particles be entangled at
different points in time as well as
space
I mean essentially yes that's what they
are they they can become entangled and
then become unentangled and so at which
point they are only entangled for that
period of time I'm not sure if you're
um
your uh
if that's what you're asking but yes
they're not just because they're
entangled it doesn't mean they're always
entangled right
all right
uh Nate Chaplin wants to know what my
favorite movie is my favorite movie is
Beetlejuice it's an 80s movie
uh
it is from what 89 I think
um it's it's an old like Tim Burton
movie I I like it it's just uh I mean it
might be some Nostalgia I guess but I
think it's a great movie
um
but like
yeah I think that's uh uh probably
um a landslide for that movie
uh then after that Stardust is is really
good I like Stardust
uh as you can see back here I've got a
bunch of DVDs there they are this is my
DVD Shelf
I think at this angle all you can see
you can basically see like the TV shows
I've got uh what is that friends
um this is fringe and then I've got some
Stargate sg1 and Stargate Atlantis is
the white one over here and
um the movies are up higher they go up
up to the ceiling
oh Sega Saturn man I forgot I forgot
Sega standard even existed
uh why do birds get electrocuted on a
live wire
uh well they do kind of
it's just that
um the wire is
a better conductor than they are and so
they they land on it and it does go
through them a smidge
a little bit
uh I don't it might be enough like for
like a little tingle on their feet which
is probably why they do it
um but they're not gonna they're not
gonna die or anything
the wire is carrying most of the load
how much longer will fusion fusion just
be a joke uh I mean I don't think it's a
joke
I think that we shouldn't ever trust
anybody's estimates of how long it's
going to take
because we just don't know but we do
progress we do you know inch closer and
closer to successful
successful uh
laughs
uh you know successful Fusion processes
but the problem is that
I mean one of the problems there's a lot
of problems engineering wise but one of
the physical problems is that we have to
do it at a temperature that's like 10
times as hot as the core of the Sun
the the sun can get away with it because
it has a lot of particles and so it can
it can take advantage of something we
like to call uh Quantum tunneling
but if we're talking about a little tiny
reactor on Earth and I mean big to us
but small to you know it's just a
building-sized reactor we're talking
about a nuclear reactor
it's it's going to take a lot more a lot
more heat to fuse the nuclei together
because there aren't enough particles
for tunneling to help
and so that is a problem in it at those
kinds of temperatures it's very
difficult to keep things stable
and so but we do our technology does
improve over time and we've gotten
better and better at it
uh and we do manage to get it going it's
just not giving us more energy than we
put into it yet so
uh we still have a ways to go but I'm
not about to sit here and try and
predict how long it's going to take
uh
upside down what does that say Amanda
Manda siba
thanks for the Super Chat
uh they want to know how do photons
become entangled I assume that it's not
something doable at home but what's the
simplest process I think the simplest
process would just to be to send a laser
through
uh there's a a specific kind of Crystal
what is it called a bbo crystal I think
um and what this material does this
Crystal does is it takes photons and
splits them in half so uh it basically
takes the energy of a photon and splits
it between two photons of half the
energy they're still photons but they
now have half the energy half the
frequency
uh and that's and then they're entangled
at least until you measure one
and I think that's the easiest way to go
but a laser is going to have a lot of
photons
and so in order to do this properly you
need a laser that could like turn on and
off ideally it would be a a single
Photon source as they're called and
uh I've never actually seen one in
person I know they do exist
um and they get used in Optics labs and
stuff at universities all the time but
um that's the easiest way just send the
photon through this specific kind of
Crystal and it'll do it for you
uh Karina's Diddy's uh oh I think I had
my
TP add-on enabled
um
anyways have you ever had vegetarian
stroganoff
uh I've never had stroganoff at all
so uh I'm I'm a pretty picky eater
I I have very specific textural needs
and so uh stroganoff just sounds a
little too
off texturally for me
and so I've never actually tried it
uh let's see here what do we got
foreign
what would happen if wormhole
wait
David Nelson how is information lost in
a black hole if everything stops from
our perspective at the Event Horizon
wouldn't it then be theoretically
available forever
see that's the thing uh that's at least
one of the things
black holes are something we don't know
a heck of a lot about
uh at least what happens inside now
there are some hypotheses that would
help explain things but again we don't
have
uh we we don't have a lot of data of
black hole event Horizons you know
basically zero
uh the closest we've gotten is the
um sort of the photon sphere
basically
uh which is this bright ring that we end
up seeing when we take a picture of a
black hole we have the accretion disk
that goes in and then it goes black for
a second and then there's this white
ring and then it's black on the inside
of that that white ring
uh is the photon sphere and it's
basically
um inside of that sphere light falls
into the black hole
unless it's coming straight out which
usually it isn't
and so uh inside the photon sphere we
don't really know much let alone inside
the inside the Event Horizon and so
things get tricky and so we're kind of
working from a theoretical standpoint
we're trying to make
statements about black holes based
purely on the models that we have that
we have tested in other areas and we
know work
and so uh I mean there could be a whole
video about this in fact I tried to film
a conversation a wife reacts video last
October
and it became clear after like 20
minutes or so that uh I didn't
understand it as well as I needed to to
explain it to her and so the the footage
from that video just sits on an external
hard drive until I'm ready for it
um and so I don't I don't understand
that well enough to make a video
that's about the extent of of my
knowledge
um
uh
thanks for the super chat
um
I think is uh how you might pronounce
that I don't know what that came off
like in the microphone but
um it's just a string of s's as a
username uh thanks for the Super Chat uh
is the original still around or are the
Clones running in the Asylum um I mean
most of the Clones that you know stick
around long term I mean they're around
you know
uh but I am the original I'm the
original
so I say
so wouldn't you like to know
uh let's see
uh the closer the solar system the
closest solar system outside Alpha
Centauri uh has an exoplanet and the
potential habitable zone do you think we
live in a region where this is common in
the Milky Way I don't even think it's
the region of the Milky Way I think I
mean maybe if you consider the entire
the like this distance a ring all the
way around because if you get too close
to the core things get a little
uh a little uh
what's the word I'm going for
um violent maybe
um it's not very habitable in there but
out at this distance about halfway out
from the core
um and even further out if we want to go
further but uh in here I we keep looking
at stars all over the Galaxy
um at least in the range that we can see
and they all seem to have planets uh
many of which in the habitable zone not
all of them Rocky some of them are gas
giants but
uh I think planets just planets in
general are very common for this
generation of stars
I don't think it's about our specific
location in the galaxy
foreign
what are your thoughts on biological
immortality is it even possible I mean I
hope so uh I don't know what that would
entail I mean there are several aspects
to it that things we'd have to alter
about ourselves to make us immortal
um I think digital immortality will
probably come sooner
but
uh I I hope that biological immortality
is the thing and I hope that it comes
before I uh you know get too old that
would be nice
let's see here
uh your tensor video was really
intuitive thanks uh I feel like I could
probably do better now you know it's
like three or four years old at this
point I think three
um but yeah I mean I tried I tried what
I could tensors were something I had to
learn myself I had to teach myself in
grad school
uh for my thesis and then I ended up
taking a mathematical physics class
where it was kind of covered for a
couple weeks at the end uh but what I
had learned myself
I I learned more than I learned in those
couple of weeks in the class
um
but oddly enough my teacher the teacher
for that class was my thesis advisor and
so she knew that I was that I I was well
versed in the in the world of tensors at
that point
um but the last topic the last that she
did four topics in the class and the
last one was up for a vote and everyone
voted tensor analysis so I was kind of
just stuck kind of reviewing what I
already knew
uh let's see
how is it the black holes can grow if
from a sufficiently far away Observer
the in Falling object never crosses the
Horizon yeah this is an issue
that we actually this is an issue we
have with black holes
um
I I think it's an indication that we
need to learn more about black holes
before we start making statements about
things like an event horizon
because the Event Horizon is also
considered a mathematical Singularity
it's just removable by a change of
coordinates whereas the one at the
center where we say that all the masses
collapsed to is not removable it is a
mathematical issue with black holes and
so the fact that we can sit there and we
can watch something fall in from a
distance and it'll never cross the Event
Horizon but the thing falling in will
definitely observe themselves cross it
well as if it's as if it's not even
there is a problem that leads me to
believe and this is my personal opinion
uh that
that we don't quite have black holes
figured out
and
and so I think that the
the limit of our model is before we even
get to the event horizon and so I don't
think that
that we can actually answer that
question I think the fact that that
happens is a
an indication of the problem
uh let's see here uh Stargate Atlantis
is underappreciated I agree
uh Jonathan Hayden well hopefully I'm
saying that right thanks for the Super
Chat
um did the jwst disprove The Big Bang
Theory absolutely not
what the the observations from jwst
the James Webb Space Telescope what what
they have
shown us is not that the Big Bang Theory
is bogus because that's ridiculous we
have a century of evidence to support it
what the observations show us is that we
don't quite understand Galactic
formation
because we can look at it and we can see
that galaxies are forming sooner than we
expected
and
the the thing is we we always imagine
that galaxies kind of formed gradually
where like they started with like a seed
black hole like a supermassive black
hole and then grew out from there and
form Stars around them and it was this
gradual process and if they formed
sooner if they were fully formed sooner
than we expected then what that means is
their formation process is different
that somehow they form really fast
and that is something that you know
astrophysicists are going to have to
figure out but that's that's literally
all these observations have done is
they've shown us that we have some more
to to understand about Galaxy formation
and that's great that's great
observation to have made right it's
always exciting when we find out that
we're wrong about something because it
means that there's more to learn
let's see uh Marduk 427 thanks for the
Super Chat uh if all observers are right
then does that not mean we live in the
past further
uh and present all at once oh future I
think you meant future their past future
and present all at once
um
no I don't think so because I
I don't think that the past and the
future actually exist
I mean we can make predictions
we can make measurements of the past and
we can make predictions of the past and
we can make predictions of the future
and I think that
that uh that gives us the impression
that the past and future exists but they
they don't
exist
and at least that's my opinion I know
that there are other physicists that
think that the block universe is a thing
and that all of it exists together in
one big block and we're just kind of
moving through it
uh with no will of our own and I I can't
get behind that but
um it doesn't neither interpretation
means that we're living the past future
and present all at once they're
definitely happening at different times
um and so that's I guess that's what I
have to say about that
uh thanks for all the great videos
thanks for watching uh I I have a lot of
fun making these things and it's really
good to know that they're being
appreciated and I appreciate uh
everything
uh y'all do for me whether it's watching
or liking or sharing or whatever
uh because it makes this you know it
makes this my job and that's really
great
for someone with like chronic illnesses
and disabilities and stuff so
let's see here
man this chat is going crazy
I thought I saw something
about teaming up with Dr Becky I can't
find the comment now but I should have
pinned it
um
yeah I mean actually
Becky if if I had a good idea for us to
collab on I'm sure she would be open to
it
um we had the privilege of of
I had the privilege of meeting her in
New York in September and that was
really cool very great person just as
wonderful as you you imagine she is
uh have you thought on making physics
courses I do you mean like like YouTube
courses like the new feature they rolled
out I have thought about it I don't know
if I have time exactly but it could be
cool I'm not I'm not opposed to it
foreign
[Music]
thanks for the Super Chat do black holes
need singularities uh no actually
um they have singularities if all you do
is
use general relativity you get
singularities and that's essentially
what originally predicted black holes
but very few physicists actually think
the singularity is a real thing we we're
pretty sure that it just means that we
have something else to figure out and
people are you know making suggestions
like
I know there's one this there's a string
theory hypothesis which frankly isn't a
theory it's already a hypothesis so like
this is a hypothesis within another
hypothesis so take this with a grain of
salt but uh these string hypothesis as
it should be called there's no
experimental evidence for it
um
for it to become a theory so the string
hypothesis would suggest that
uh would be consistent with the idea
that the you know the particles and all
that like information or whatever you
want to call it is compressed onto the
Event Horizon in from three dimensions
into two Dimensions as these like
collections of strings
you know very much like Planck scale
strings
um and so I think that
you know there are other suggestions as
far as like how you would remove
singularities from that model because
ideally that's what you would want to do
when you figure a new idea out you would
want to
um you would want to have it like fix
problems like singularities and uh you
know Infinities and stuff like that
uh oh inside of nataru says the string
theory exists I mean the the model
exists again I would not call it a
theory it's very poorly named uh after
decades and decades it has yet to
produce any
you know testable
predictions
um and so
it can't it can't be a theory theory is
a very
coveted word in science
and so without experimental evidence you
can't consider something a theory it's
the string hypothesis
uh what is your full-time job this is my
full-time job actually I used to teach
at the University level part-time
but that career never actually like went
anywhere
and so
uh
and so I I I'm I'm I was I consider
myself very lucky to have this
and to have gotten out of Academia and
um to be doing this full-time this is
much more
rewarding uh much less stressful uh
teaching part-time is not a good
experience
um if you want I have some idea of how
it is uh there's uh a YouTuber a small
YouTuber named uh Dr Andrea Collier I
think I just found recently
and she put out a video maybe a couple
months ago regarding
um adjunct faculty at universities and
what that's like it's Horror Show
um I don't recommend it for anybody
honestly
uh let's see here
uh physics oh says I can't stay long but
I wanted to stop by and say congrats on
10 years huge uh yeah thank you Eric
um if anybody's wondering that is uh
his name's Eric he uh was my
expert consultant on the quantum field
Theory video I just put out so
um he does live streams sometimes you
might wanna check him out physics o I
think is the channel
um
that's uh up I'll pin him to the top I
don't know how I feel about this but
there pin him to the top of the feed I
don't know if you can actually click on
things in there but uh
let's see
how to be better at solving problems uh
yeah this is a challenge I something I
did in
in my classes
was I
I would give students like a procedure
you know I I kind of got an idea of like
the kinds of problems that you see
in
um in like introductory physics because
that's basically all I ever got to teach
as a part-time teacher but I I kind of
got these like
processes going I don't know if I
actually have
any to share with you with them nope
apparently not okay
I was gonna screen share it but uh but
no I got like a procedure for like
solving Newton's Laws problems or
solving energy problems or momentum
problems or you know electric circuit
problems the kind of stuff that you
would see in those classes and so uh if
people were struggling they didn't have
like an intuitive understanding of how
to solve problems because solving
problems is kind of an art form
um I could at least give them a
guideline like follow these steps and
then um and then by the end of the
course most people like got a feel for
it just by like going through the
motions enough
right it's all about practice
uh
why does dark energy violate the energy
conservation I I don't know why I mean
nobody knows why
uh but we know that it does
and
at least as far as we can tell right if
space is expanding and over time there's
more and more space then there has to be
more and more Dark Energy because the
density the dark energy density must
remain constant
uh is it possible that it changes maybe
but then we'd have to like com we have
to come up with a whole new model that
allows for changeable Dark Energy the
reason dark energy is constant is for a
a mathematical reason within general
relativity
um for those of you who have had uh
calculus 2 where you do integrals right
and you know how if you do indefinite
integrals you end up with a plus c at
the end where you always have to add the
plus C or your calc teacher is going to
like Mark you down half the points on
the test or something they get real
sticklers about those plus C's but you
get like a plus c on the end that's what
dark energy is it's like the plus c
uh Char McKay brought up uh Diana Cowan
situation uh yeah if you haven't heard
uh if you follow her don't or whatever
um she is struggling with
a uh what is it called chronic fatigue
syndrome as a result of a covet
infection so
um
her husband's kind of like
holding down the fort right now she had
to close her office recently it's been
uh a mess
um
those of us who are friends have you
know offered to help here and there but
like you know that her and her husband
Kyle are making the best decisions they
can and
um you know so if you weren't aware that
is something that's happening
what is your opinion on the current
YouTube environment in regard to new
science Educators trying to start a
channel on their own would you consider
that a good career trajectory
uh I think that
I mean it ended up being a good career
trajectory for me but I think if I had
planned on that from the beginning
it would not have been good for my
mental health because it took
like I mean I was basically functioning
at a loss
for two years it was basically a hobby I
was dumping money into
it and that's how I thought of it at the
time I just thought of it like a hobby
and so uh I wasn't really all that like
invested in it I was just making like
quickie
three minute videos about things
um and you know you I always want the
stuff the content to be successful you
want what you're making your art to be
successful but
um I wasn't like basing my whole life on
it or anything my career
uh and then the third year I was
breaking even
and so I was making enough money to
cover expenses for the hobby which was
nice you know I wasn't going into the
hole anymore which was good because I
was not
working part-time at like three
different schools was not a good place
uh
and so it wasn't I didn't actually start
to like
really actually make money at this until
like year four or five and so it's not
something you can just like
you know you can't like you know how
when you switch from one job to another
you you know you're making money at the
new job and you know how much money
you're making and this is not like that
uh and so
um can it be a good career trajectory
yes but
um and they're certainly like you know
you got to put effort into it but also
there is an aspect of luck as well
and so just something to keep in mind
right
uh and even even with that it takes it
can take a while before it's viable and
so you can't really you can't really
just quit your life
at least you know unless you're like
younger I think younger people have an
easier time
moving things around in their life then
then someone in my position because I
didn't even start it until
I was 30 something young thirties so
it's
I'm I'm middle-aged I guess is what you
would you'd say now it's kind of weird
to say that out loud
uh let's see what motivated you to make
YouTube videos in the first place this
is a great question
uh I I was teaching right and
uh like I said I wasn't trying to make
this a job but
uh I did want an outlet right I I was
learning things I learned things and I
was continuing to learn things that were
more you know Advanced physics general
relativity quantum mechanics that sort
of thing and I needed an outlet for that
and
and I teaching just wasn't doing it
right like sometimes I would do like a a
q a at the end of a semester just like
ask me whatever you want I got to talk
about stuff then sometimes but never
anything in much detail and you know
when you're teaching like there's a
course description that has says
specifically what you're allowed to
teach and what you aren't
and so
uh it was limiting me and I wanted to
talk about other stuff and so that's
kind of how it started
it started as an outlet
and I was so excited I was so excited to
be
to have an outlet and to be doing that
that I was super hyper on camera and I
kind of leaned into that
um hence the like overall theme of the
channel but uh since then I've obviously
calmed down a bit
but but yeah so that's kind of how it
started it just started as a a hobby an
outlet for me
I just stayed here to say
congratulations thanks
uh what's weirder magnets or gravity uh
well
if you're talking physics before 1900
magnets but if you're talking
after like 1915 and forward when we're
talking about general relativity
definitely gravity gravity is weirder
not even not even a contest
see
Michaela why can't Michaela wants to
know why can't photons be localized as
wave packets the way massive particles
can
you know I I don't know
this is this is kind of outside of my
field of knowledge I I don't really have
an answer for you sorry Michaela
um I don't know if it has to do with
mass specifically and the fact that it
doesn't have mass
um
I know that localization is tough with
photons right they tend to be like all
over the place but I mean we treat them
as local when we put them in defining
diagrams so I'm not sure exactly how
that works out
um you know fundamentally like
conceptually
but I don't really have I don't really
have an answer
uh a lot says love the shirt yeah thanks
it's a little retro
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
uh
I once heard Professor Leonard suskin
say that in Quantum scales particles get
entangled fairly easily
would you say that's the case I don't
know about easy easy seems
it doesn't seem like the right word
foreign
[Music]
I don't think I'd say easy
it might be more common
the more and more isolated things get
but I I don't know if I don't know if
easy is the right word there
uh thanks for the Super Chat Roman no
question just just a Super Chat thank
you so much
uh Star Trek or Star Wars oh boy
um
laughs
Star Trek is is obviously my thing I've
got uh
is it over it's kind of in the back I've
got two layers I don't know if you can
see it like above here or what is that
no up here
these silvery ones back here that's uh
Star Trek the Next Generation I've also
got the Original Series in there on
Blu-ray and DVD or something
uh but the thing is like I have Star
Wars over there too
I have both of them
they're not even they're not even the
same genre okay this is this is a hard
opinion I have right Star Trek is
science fiction Star Wars is science
fantasy
it's fantasy
right
they're like magical Wizards with laser
swords you know it's it's fantasy it's
not it just happens to take place in
space
uh and you can like both I mean Star
Trek is uh always have we'll always have
a special place in my heart at least
like old school old school Star Trek I
can't really get into the new stuff I'm
glad that it's you know bringing a new
audience into Star Trek but I can't
really get into it um although I want to
try strange new worlds I hear I hear
good things about it
um
release the ghost in your shell uh yeah
I actually have the anime movie over
here somewhere I think
uh for Ghost in the Shell
weird but I'm I'm a fan of weird
sometimes
um why do physicists think gravity is a
particle when it's curvature well I mean
we don't know that it's curvature either
we our best model for Gravity says that
it is uh and that's really all we can
say
um
but I think
most people think most physicists think
of quantum field Theory
as the new
the newest model it's the front line
they don't look at general relativity
and Quantum field theories being in
April footing they see Quantum field
theories being better
and newer
and so they think of it as being pulling
gravity into Quantum field Theory which
we can't seem to do but that would that
would turn gravity you know space time
into a field
uh which then excitations in that field
would be gravitons and so then you would
model you would draw a Feynman diagram
for Gravity using virtual gravitons but
those models don't work they don't work
and so I I think that a lot of
physicists are kind of
letting it
letting it go
um all right and jump around here
uh
let's see uh Star Wars is not as good as
it was I don't know that that's true
I I think that
you know when when
writers and and show Runners and and
movie producers and stuff when they make
new stuff they're gonna make it for new
people
right the newer stuff isn't necessarily
made for the hardcore old school fans
right in order to make the money they
want to make on it it also has to appeal
to a broader audience outside the fan
base and I think that's that's the real
problem right like when you when you try
to appeal to people outside of a fan
base then the fan base can get angry
sometimes especially the Star Wars fan
base they get
they get so angry about everything
um
uh at least the really vocal ones right
I mean I'm I'm a Star Wars fan and I
don't get angry but I think some there's
a a subset of very vocal very angry Star
Wars fans from
back in the day that that are just angry
about the new stuff but I don't think
I don't think the newer stuff sucks I
think it's just different it's different
it isn't made for the same people
all right
what was the topic of your Master's
thesis it was the hydrostatic
equilibrium of white dwarf stars
uh and so I know that sounds real boring
but typically you know the titles of
Theses are pretty boring
um but basically it's about the internal
structure of a white dwarf you know what
are they made of how do they support
themselves that sort of thing
um and it's something that had been done
before but what I was sort of adding to
the conversation was I wanted to know
whether or not
uh general relativity
could be a factor in like whether or not
the maximum mass for a white dwarf was
accurate right if I did it with general
relativity instead of Newtonian gravity
would it make a difference and it kind
of did but it was only in like the
second decimal place and so not much
if you're only rounding to one decimal
place for that mass like 1.4 solar
masses then it doesn't actually matter
uh but my calculation made it 1.44
instead of 1.40 or the other way around
man
it's been a long time since I've looked
at it but uh
that is essentially what happened there
I showed I kind of got a negative result
which isn't as exciting as a positive
one
but important nonetheless
uh let's see
let's get down to the bottom of the chat
here all right
given Advanced enough technology
do you think it would be possible to
collapse every wave function that
comprises every particle in our bodies
so that we can appear at any plate no
uh in fact you wouldn't want to I I
imagine that there are a lot of things
inside the human body inside of cells
that function because
there's an uncertainty in position and
so if you did that if you wanted to
collapse it
uh I I imagine that would be very bad
for you
uh and and so I would not I would not
recommend that
uh let's see
what force is in general relativity
there oh yeah that's that's in response
to somebody else
uh yeah I mean forces the word force is
ambiguous
right what exactly is a force this is a
video I've been thinking about for a
while but I just don't know if it would
be something that anyone would be
interested in but
um
I know I think uh
Sabine hostenfelder did one
and it was fine so I don't know maybe
I'll do one but uh
a force meant something very specific in
Newtonian mechanics
and I don't think that
and I I that the the word has sort of
changed meaning over time into something
it's more lacks you know
uh and so I would say that gravity is an
interaction uh but I would be hesitant
to call it a force
um let's see
oh uh Brenda says Einstein Fields
equations reduced to Newton uh they do
but you have to make approximations
right
um any new model has to be consistent
with the old model at least the
predictions of the old model and so
uh the predictions are consistent but
also you can make some approximations
with Einstein's Fields equations you can
take like just the time component and do
a weak field
uh and you know Earth's gravity is
considered a weak field and so when you
do that then like you do some math on it
and you can get
uh and I made a video about this where
you get poisson's equation and uh that
is essentially like the energy version
of Newton's law of gravitation
uh so it does reduce to it but I I
wouldn't I still wouldn't call it a
force
um force is probably something the word
is probably something we should just
leave in Newtonian mechanics
uh do you think nuclear power is a good
thing I this might be a hot take but yes
I I know that we have to kind of factor
in public opinion when we make decisions
like that
public opinion matters but uh in my
opinion which is not an expert opinion
on nuclear power let me let me just
preface that uh but my personal opinion
is that it is a good thing I mean even
not even Fusion but like regular old
fission nuclear plants
um we know those work and we're very
good we got really good technology for
it and
um I think
the problem is that when things go bad
they go very bad uh
and and it's scary for people it's scary
and I understand that it's scary
uh but the thing is like those accidents
happened because either mismanaged or
old equipment right things weren't
maintained properly uh proper procedures
weren't followed that sort of thing it
wasn't because like we suck at nuclear
fission
um it was because somebody screwed up
and so uh
and I guess like that's something you
certainly have to account for as well
somebody's gonna screw up eventually and
so you got to have like fail safes in
place and now that we've we've been
doing fission for a long time at this
point we know what kind of fail safes
and Technologies we need in place to you
know help prevent you know stupid
decisions
uh so yes I think nuclear power is good
and if we expect to get off of fossil
fuels
anytime soon we're gonna need it
and I think it's a tragedy that that
nuclear power plants are being torn down
rather than fixed
uh let's see
foreign
ergy so says uh realize realize realize
uh
some some good uh
was that a pun I don't know if that's a
pun
uh it says dark energy is a placeholder
for ignorance uh it's more than that
uh do we have ignorance about it yes but
I I it's more than just a placeholder
for ignorance it is something that the
models predict
and when we look out and we look at
observations we do see the effects
of that stuff whatever it is existing
and so it's more than just
a prediction there's also an observation
and it's more than just ignorance we
know a little bit
uh our observations appear to be
consistent with the model we have
uh with you know Dark Energy being a
thing
so
uh it's more than ignorance
I think that on it's calling it
ignorance undersells it a little bit a
bit
foreign
do you think PhD a PhD is important uh
I think it depends uh it wasn't
important for me I didn't get one I got
a master's degree and quit school
because a master's degree was enough for
me to teach
and that's ultimately what I wanted to
do and going for a PhD you you what you
learn when you get past your master's
degree is you end up learning like
laughs
you end up learning a lot
of detail about a very specific thing a
specific thing that not a lot of people
know about uh but mostly what you're
learning when you're you're doing a PhD
is
uh you're learning how to write Grant
proposals and you're learning how to uh
you know schmooze potential investors
and you're you're learning how to like
you know socialize at parties and stuff
like because
you know when it comes to funding
funding requires socializing and so
there are a lot of very specific social
kind of skills that you get
um in in a PhD program but like I said
you also learn how to write Grant
proposals and you learn how to write
papers and there's a lot of writing
skills that you learn uh and
I wasn't I wasn't planning on becoming
like a full professor and doing research
and it wasn't really my my goal
and so I quit at the at the master's
degree but if that is your goal if
that's something you want to do if you
want to be somebody who does a lot of
research then by all means get your PhD
then that that sounds like it's
something for you
uh let's see what is the viscosity of
space well space isn't a fluid so it
can't really have a viscosity
um it does kind of you can think of it
as like a
attention I guess that's not really
attention though uh because it's not
it's not even it's not even a fabric
space time isn't even really a fabric we
can we we call it the fabric of
space-time by analogy only
but it's not really any of those things
and so I would be hesitant to say that
it has attention or a volumetric tension
or or a viscosity or anything like that
um I mean I have said that
um
I I have said that it it the the
constant inside of uh Einstein's field
equation is kind of an elasticity if you
want to think of it like a fabric you
can think of that constant as an elastic
constant but uh which makes space-time
very rigid
uh but it's just an analogy
uh there there is no fluid right back at
the beginning of the stream I talked
about how in the 1800s we wanted to
think everything was a fluid we wanted
to to to think that you know electricity
was a fluid and the heat was a fluid and
and and light was traveling through a
fluid and everything it was the fluid
Paradigm sort of what we refer to
um it as historically but
we have learned that these things are
not they're not they're not fluids there
are some aspects of fluid mechanics that
we can sometimes use
right like I've I learned I I used a few
aspects of fluid mechanics in my
Master's thesis to model electrons but
all it doesn't mean electrons are fluids
it just means there's some similar
Behavior right
and so just like space time isn't a
fabric it does have some similar
Behavior to a fabric but it doesn't make
it a fabric
right so space time is not a fabric it
is not a fluid it's not any of those
things it is its own thing
um
uh Daniel Boland what is your personal
explanation of for the Fermi Paradox
thanks for the Super Chat by the way uh
what is your personal explanation of the
Fermi Paradox I think
that were early
and I don't know that we're going to be
too early but I think that we are first
or at the very least second
and that the first one is like on the
other side of the Galaxy or in another
galaxy or something right but we're
measuring inside the Galaxy so if
there's like
there's there might be only like
actually like two civilizations right
now and there's ours and then there's
one like on the other side of the Galaxy
that we can't contact
and so I think I think we're just early
this is the first time things have kind
of calmed down enough
for
planets to form and be around long
enough for life to happen
and from the looks of things
planets that can actually hold life
don't appear to be all that common
um and so I I think that we're
we're just early
but again that's just a personal opinion
on the subject
thank you for being the high energy
scientist yeah thanks I try to like
you know I mean I don't actually have to
try I mean I'm just super excited about
this if anything I'm
intentionally bringing myself down
um honestly I wish I could search the
chat uh I've seen Igan Chris show up a
couple times and then I lose his
comments so
uh it's kind of a bummer
all I know what his icon is I could
probably scroll really fast uh VTS 747
thank you for the Super Chat
I don't see it
uh Cesar Moya thanks for the Super Chat
Caesar wants to know
uh the world is a better play oh this
world is a better place with you
teaching us about it thanks uh thank you
that these are
I I appreciate
okay
um
I I'm I'm a huge fan of positive
feedback so uh thank you so much Caesar
for for your kind words
okay
man this chat goes so fast when I do a
public stream
I think I'm there I saw that already
uh
tophbe Fong thank you for the Super Chat
a lot of these super chats don't even
have questions that's wild
uh
talk to you lose it sounds like the next
DC Comic character uh yeah thank
goodness I'm not a doctor that would be
they'd make me sound like a villain I
think at that point
uh at least at least uh
just saying you know just being Nick
Lucid is is a little less
sounds a little less dark in that case
um
what are my thoughts on Monde that is
the uh modified Newtonian Dynamics is
what that stands for uh and it's a
suggestion for
for
um a replacement for Dark Matter uh it's
not bad that it was suggested
I think that you know
as a scientific Community we consider
all possible suggestions that could work
um but we have considered man's been
around a long time and we have
considered it and uh in order for that
to actually replace Dark Matter it would
have to work differently the
modifications would have to work
differently on different scales and
that's just it's kind of ridiculous at
that point
um and so a lot of proponents of mons of
modified gravity
uh also include dark matter in their
models because they know that they can't
possibly
modify everything at every level
uh and so I don't think it's a viable
model all of our evidence and we have a
ton of evidence
and it's there's a ton of evidence that
says that it is matter it does behave
like matter
we might not know exactly what kind of
matter it is but we know what kind of
properties it has and so we kind of know
what we're looking for
uh but but it is matter right
overwhelming evidence and this is not
something that we've come to easily dark
matter is an idea an explanation that we
came to
kicking and screaming and dragging our
feet
it's probably the most reluctant
explanation for anything it's certainly
in astrophysics
uh but eventually you you get to a point
where the stack of evidence is so large
that if you're ignoring it you're just
being
you're being an ignorant scientist at
that point because you're you're
pretending like this pile doesn't exist
in the and the the most basic form of
the word ignorance right you are
ignoring it
and so it's it's overwhelming
oh there is
eigen Chris saying
they tried to do a super chat
but I can't find your original comments
uh Chris hopefully you can comment it
again
uh feel free to do normal comment and
I'll see if I can find it
um also I can Chris uh it's a good
channel to check out if you haven't
already uh if you're into really deep
mathematical explanations of things
I can Chris is where it's at
ah here we go he did already
uh
uh eigen Chris wants to know my question
was uh have you ever studied condensed
matter
no I mean not in any detail you know you
get those like you get a general
overview when you're going through intro
classes and stuff um but there really
wasn't a condensed matter or physicists
in the department that I was
uh learning in so it wasn't really an
opportunity
uh some things like renormalization and
spontaneous symmetry breaking apparently
come from condensed matter that's
possible
I know very little about it
to be honest
um I I don't think I don't even think I
know anyone who knows anything about it
because I think I
I don't think condensed matter was ever
like the big thing that everyone wanted
to be in uh and study and so I don't
think that
at least not when I was going through
school
and so it wasn't really I mean it was It
was kind of
a side topic
back then
uh do you have any kids no kids I have
uh nieces and nephews
I'm a very proud uncle
how do molecular orbitals work uh that
is a loaded question
molecular orbitals
Okay so
when atoms form into molecules they end
up forming these like hybrid orbitals
right because remember an orbital isn't
like something that that isn't a
physical object that sits there it's a
probability distribution
and so when two atoms come together to
make a molecule that can change what the
probability distribution looks like
where where we expect to find electrons
we end up expecting to find them more at
where we would think to find a bond you
know in like old school molecular models
and and and so like the distribution can
change uh and things get really
complicated I mean just explaining atoms
alone is
almost beyond the scope of quantum
mechanics uh in order to do it we end up
having to like make little
approximations and Tack on correction
terms and stuff just to make it like
match reality and that's that's just
with a hydrogen atom if you want to do
like helium or lithium or like some
other larger element
uh you're gonna run into problems run
into obstacles where like you're
basically dealing with a many body
problem and many body problems are
notorious for
not being solvable and so
uh we have that problem so it's
difficult to explain that
in any like significant detail
but essentially
uh
when atoms form molecules it they can
form these these hybrid orbitals orbital
hybridization is a whole field of study
all by itself
let's see
uh Midwest wind thanks for the super
chat if I start walking in place in a
circle
and I walk faster and faster toward 99
the speed of light when I stop walking
in place am I in the far future
uh yeah I mean assuming no one did
anything with you while you were
while you were uh walking in place
because
you can still interact with the
surrounding space it's not like you're
in some isolated bubble or anything
like that new newer oh what is that like
10 12 years ago but
um the newer version of like the time
machine
um where I like the machine like forms a
bubble or a protective bubble around
them you wouldn't do that if you were
just pacing in a circle
um but time would certainly pass slower
for you than the surrounding environment
and you would end up in the future but
uh
it'd be hard to like protect yourself at
that point
let's see here I don't want to try not
to miss too many people
um
foreign
oh oh wow we've been doing this for a
while haven't we
uh let's see
uh
how much effort do we need to make
element 120 uh
those larger elements are they're tough
and they don't last very long so even if
you can make it you've got to detect it
really fast or it's going to Decay into
a smaller element and so this is why
we're having harder and harder time
finding larger elements now there is a
theoretical maximum is it like
156 or so I can't remember what the
number is I think it's like 150
something
um
and so uh there is a theoretical maximum
where like this they were the repulsion
of protons is just too much and the the
nucleus just can't can't stay together
uh but we're not anywhere near it in
terms of discovering elements
see
foreign
why does current always flow in the
opposite direction of the flow of
electrons uh that's a definition issue
uh because electric current
isn't
really a thing
right I mean the flow of electrons is
what's actually happening but even there
it's not even really like a flow of
electrons you can't think of it as
individual electrons
uh electric current is what you get when
you've got a whole bunch of electrons
and they're kind of like drifting
through a circuit
uh the drift
is what we kind of abstractly call an
electric current
um but
the
the issue is that
when we first defined it this was back
like at the beginning of when we thought
it was a fluid when we thought
everything was fluid we thought this
fluid it was positively charged and it
was flowing through the wires
um and so it took like 150 years after
that definition for us to finally
realize
that it was
negative that it was the negative charge
that was flowing around and it was just
leaving behind positive holes and so uh
that
and at that point we're not going to
change
150 Years Learning the current is flow
of positive charge no one is going to
change we're just gonna like pretend
like it's positive and move on right the
only thing that's going to make us
change is if our calculations are wrong
and we spent 150 years doing
calculations that were just fine so
um it's just a definition problem it's
not
a reality problem
uh Casey Hodge what is the mini body
problem no I didn't say that without
defining it didn't I uh the many okay so
you've got
just as an example you've got the Earth
and the moon right the moon orbits the
earth and then the Earth kind of wobbles
in place a little bit because of the
Gravity from the moon so they affect
each other
that system is called a two body system
and if you want to include the sun in
that right the Moon and the Earth orbit
the Sun
now you have a three body problem
which a three body problem is already
like
mostly unsolvable outside of like some
specific circumstances where like the
sun earth Moon system is solvable
because the sun is so much bigger than
the earth and moon that like you can
make approximations and you know get rid
of the like problems
but
uh in general three body problems are
mostly mostly not solvable and when you
have more than three you have a many
body problem
um it's like four and up we just kind of
Clump them all into many so you have a
many body problem and so when you've got
something like an atom that's made of
you know I don't know 29 well let's pull
up the
right let's just take a look let's take
a look I'm going to screen share because
I set this up and I want to use it
Okay so
we're gonna google
I'm gonna pull up a periodic table of
elements here
all right so
here we've got a periodic table of
elements
and you can see the hydrogen atom right
the hydrogen has one proton
these decimals are just because they
take an average of all the Isotopes a
weighted average but there's one proton
and one electron right and then in the
helium there is
two protons two electrons
sorry two protons two electrons and two
neutrons so that's six particles already
now you can probably treat the nucleus
as one thing that's usually a pretty
good approximation it's all pretty
cramped into one clump and so even then
it's like three particles right it's two
electrons in a nucleus
but then that's it just keeps going up
from there right if you you've got
copper
copper here has 29 protons right but
even if you take the whole nucleus and
you Clump it into one thing there are
still 29 electrons in orbitals around
that nucleus that is a many body problem
and so that's that's what we mean by
many body problems it this gets out of
hand real fast
and so you have to make approximations
like oh these electrons don't interact
very much or I can make a prediction
about the outermost electron and copper
which we can do and then you just assume
that like all 28 of the other electrons
are part of the nucleus and so now it's
a two body problem
uh approximately
and so that's essentially what we're
we're saying
and so we're saying
that uh a many broader problem just has
many objects or many particles that are
all interacting together
look
uh all right
uh so I said during during engineering
we used to mispronounce poisson all the
time
uh yeah people have problems with I mean
even I have problems with French names
for whatever reason
I can't
I can't get it
um and like most of the time though
French people are pretty like
uh it's like
I try so hard
and and I just can't like
um although from from what I'm told I do
better with French names than I do with
German ones which is weird because I
took German in high school which you
think I'd be better at it
uh but apparently not
um but it does help uh with French it
does help that my wife speaks French
so uh I have I have someone living in
the house with me that that can help
uh all right
uh snake
thanks for the Super Chat uh what blows
your mind the most about the How the
Universe Works
I have a hard time
with
well I mean I have I mean it's I have a
hard time with Quantum field Theory it
feels so different to me than anything
else
uh but I think that what blows my mind
I think what blows my mind is biology to
be perfectly honest
the the fact that like
inorganic chemistry became organic
chemistry which became a biological
organism is just wild to me
right and I I think it's because like we
have trouble comprehending the time
scales over which this has has occurred
um and so that's
that I think that's the problem I think
so biology really fascinates me in a way
that blows my mind and so I think it
helps that you know my wife's a
biologist and so I just get to hear
about it all the time it's awesome
um let's see uh Sean Corey Sean H Corey
says veritasium has two YouTube videos
about how electricity flows and layers
he does
uh if you look in the video description
of the first one you'll notice that he
links to one of my old videos uh he
cited my video in his video
um so people that are coming over being
like oh he copied you he didn't copy me
none of us own topics
um and he cited my video in in the
description so uh Derek and I are cool
we know each other so it's fine
foreign
lots of repeat super chats thanks Toph
Bay Fung
hopefully I'm saying that right
uh Zero by one publishing uh why can't
anyone accurately depict gravity in 3D
they always use that damped 2D
trampoline graphic uh that's not true
actually
um I have had a hard time with it it's
difficult to draw out
but I know that there is one
graphic
see if we can find it
gravity
there's one animation
by a guy named Lucas
let me pull this up okay
screen sharing looks something like this
uh and so uh
uh the L in Lucas is a one so this is
one ukus VB
um Lucas does a lot of really cool
animations I I don't know if it's is it
Mathematica I don't know I don't know
what I don't know what he does does it
with but
um
this is the best one that I've seen
and it's sort of a three-dimensional
version of
how gravity works so you got something
like I don't know maybe it's it's going
around in a circle which isn't something
that objects normally do but it you know
if you want your your animation to Loop
and be
appealing you know
um
you make it go in a circle but basically
that's
what we're looking at as uh the mass the
white Mass there the star sort of it's
exaggerated but uh the only thing that
warps space this much is a black hole
but
um it it's poor it's kind of pulls space
and time inward
and and so this is I think this is the
best we can do and technically this is
one dimension lower than it should be it
should be four-dimensional but I think
the motion kind of accounts for time
so just something to uh
it does exist is what I'm saying
um all right
I think we'll go for another 10 minutes
or so it'll put us to two hours and
we'll we'll call it a day
we'll call it a stream
if you will
uh
our minds are not capable of
understanding the fourth dimension uh
maybe I at least not a
fourth spatial Dimension but I mean we
understand how time works and as far as
we know time is the fourth dimension but
a fourth space Dimension would certainly
be
a little beyond our understanding
um our our brain's ability to understand
anyone's ability
uh let's see
am I doing any Nobel prize winning
research no I'm not doing any research
at all I don't want that kind of stress
I am an educator
and so my goal is to make sure is to
help other people understand
physics and astronomy and astrophysics
and that stuff the stuff that's my bread
and butter
that's my my goal in life is to help as
many people as possible understand
uh is there a limit like the Chandra
sekar limit which stops the black hole
from collapsing to a singularity not
that we know of
uh we know that there's so the Chandra
secar limit is the limit that I was
deriving in my Master's thesis that's
what it's called
the upper Mass limit for white dwarf
which is about 1.4 times the mass of the
Sun 1.4 solar masses as we would call it
and there's one for a neutron star
there's an upper limit for a neutron
star
which means after the neutron star hits
that limit it will collapse into a black
hole right above the Chandra secar limit
for a white dwarf it will collapse into
a neutron star and then there's a likely
what there's another one for neutrons
there's a neutron limit which after
which will collapse into a black hole
these are very clear well-defined limits
and
the
uh the black hole wouldn't really have
one
I mean there might be one for quarks we
haven't figured out what it is yet it
doesn't appear to be a thing
um
but at some point you know you're going
to get inside of it's going to collapse
so much that you get inside the Event
Horizon and so once the Event Horizon
forms
we don't actually know what happens to
the matter in there
we just don't we just don't know
we can take some wild guesses but we
don't actually know
uh
let's see mid uh Midwest wind thanks for
the the additional Super Chat uh if if
I'm running in that Circle going okay
does the rest of the outside world see
me as an almost Frozen in Time super
massive barely human well okay no
because
foreign
this is a uh something that that people
get confused about with relativity all
the time
uh and it's something I don't think I've
actually cleared up in
any video I've ever made so that could
be something for the future but
basically when we when you have
particles right we have particles we
send them in a particle accelerator and
we can make them go like 99.99 the speed
of light you know we're on this giant
ring
we don't see them sitting still inside
the ring they are going at that speed
measured by us they are traveling around
the circle at the speed that we're
measuring them to be zipping past us
like as a blur you know
um it's just that this the time within
them
is has slowed down but the exterior time
the time that we see it moving through
space that's fine
that that's our time
it's the internal time so like when you
have a spaceship
right that's traveling at say 90 the
speed of light toward Alpha Centauri
uh
if somebody's if somebody's stationary
relative to earth right and they're just
sitting out there in a space station and
they see the ship go by they're gonna
measure it zip past in a blur going at
90 the speed of light it's not they're
gonna see it sitting still but if they
take a picture and they look inside the
ship in a window they're gonna see
everything inside the ship moving slowly
right so there's a it's it's inside
versus outside interior versus exterior
right
um in fact this is this is just a
carryover from even Newtonian mechanics
right we've we've always had
there's always been a difference between
internal things and external things uh
Newton's second law for example
is the net external Force there are all
sorts of internal forces inside of your
body but only the external ones are
actually going to move your body around
right so
we have
internal versus external and the same
kind of idea carries over into
relativity
where there is an internal time and an
external time
it's kind of the the best way to look at
it I think
um
foreign artificer Creator says you look
fantastic thank you
uh I never played an artificer uh Druids
usually it's a d d thing for anyone
who's wondering
um although I've been exploring Fighters
recently
uh let's see
um can you mention why there are eight
gluons and not nine uh kind of Okay so
there are
three
Okay so
there are three colors for quarks right
there's red green and blue now these
these aren't actual colors they're just
labels
for a type of charge that can take on
three values we just use it we just use
colors as an analogy so that there's
there's red green and blue
at which point there's also
anti-particles that can have an
anti-charge right so there's also
anti-red anti-green and anti-blue but
because we're using colors as an analogy
we don't call them anti-red anti-green
and anti-brew we call them cyan yellow
and magenta the secondary light colors
which are opposite the Venn diagram and
actually let me
let's just
keep screen sharing at the last minute
here light then
nope nope nope not that not that
I want to open no I don't want to open
the link
open image there we go
Okay so
screen sharing so we've got something
that looks like this
and here you've got red green and blue
these are the basic colors right and
then you've got magenta yellow and cyan
so anti-red right anti-red would be
opposite this diagram from Red which
would be cyan opposite green or
anti-green would be magenta an anti-blue
would be yellow
okay
and so those are six different possible
charge values that a quark can have
now when it comes to gluons
gluons are interactions between quarks
and so in that case
uh the the glue on can kind of take on a
combo of two of the colors
and and so there end up being eight ways
we can combine the colors together if if
I go any more deeper than if I go any
deeper than this it's going to get
mathematical but basically there are
eight ways we can combine those six
different colors the red green blue and
then cyan magenta yellow
uh eight ways that don't like eliminate
each other
um and just sort of mathematically
that's how it works out but I think that
might help point you in the right
direction
all right
Dante thanks for the Super Chat uh what
is the general relativity interpretation
for the LaGrange points I actually
haven't looked into this
uh I I would like to
but there's a lot of things there's a
lot of things that we haven't really
like worked out in full
because
when something is doable and easier to
do in Newtonian mechanics we're going to
do it in denonian mechanics that's just
how it is we can get an accurate result
that's where we're going to do it and
that's LaGrange points have been around
for a long time
um
and so
I've never actually seen it worked out
in general relatively it's the same
thing with Tides right we've done Tides
before we can do Tides with Newtonian
mechanics and you can do it with general
relativity but again no one really
bothers because Newtonian mechanics is
easier and it works in that case and so
uh
I imagine that the interpretation would
be roughly the same
I'm not sure though I'd have to really
sit down with it uh I'd be mid-may for a
cool video though possibly
uh congratulations on 10 years thank you
patient ape
uh thanks for the Super Chat Marcus
um again what's your day job this is my
day job I I'm a YouTuber educational
Creator whatever you want to call it uh
I make YouTube videos
um
obviously like I have AdSense turned on
I get bad I get you know my AdSense uh
people giving super chats today uh
um I also
sell a book
that's that's a thing that I do I don't
really have another day job besides this
this is just my job but it took a while
to get here
um
I think I've got it yeah okay
I do have a book though
and something like this Advanced
theoretical physics it's not showing the
cursor okay
um anyway I Advanced theoretical physics
a historical perspective if you've been
watching my channel a while you know I'm
big on history I think we can't truly
understand something unless we know the
history behind it and so uh there's a
lot of historical stuff in here as we go
but it's Superman heavy
um I sell this this is something I sell
in an e-book and paperback uh links will
be
uh should be in the doobly-doo
I think
um anyway
uh so we do that so there's a lot of I I
you know diversify your Revenue sources
or whatever they say you know um but my
goal is to just like educate and so all
the things that I do I'm just trying to
educate people
and I used to teach but now I just do
this
um all right maybe one more question
here
uh let's make it a good one
uh let's see
after after the ring down and the merger
of the two black holes okay so there's
this little noise that they've made uh
they basically took there's a
gravitational waves
arrive at Earth right and they basically
took the frequency pattern
um and then asked themselves
what would it be like if that was a
sound right and a hearable sound and so
they took the frequency range they said
okay what if this is a sound and then
they moved it up in the human frequency
range uh and you get to hear it's like
it's like this like
silly noise I it's like two steps of
abstraction away from what it is so I
don't necessarily like the sound but
um
I think that
uh so the question here is after that
ring down is what this uh Sabas is
referring to
um there are gravitational waves
escaping from the new event horizon uh
no actually uh in order for in order for
gravitational waves to leave there has
to be some
you can't have spherical symmetry
and so once the two see the two black
holes orbiting each other generate the
the uh uh the gravitational waves once
they merge into one black hole there's
no more gravitational waves
single singular spherical
singular spherical gravitational uh
sorry gravitational sources like black
holes do not generate gravitational
waves so once they merge it's over
right it's why we're not seeing a big
sea of gravitational waves everywhere we
only pick them up right before a
collision
um okay
I think
that covers it we've been going for two
hours uh I've had a great time thank you
all for coming thank you all for the
super chats uh
Ahmad and Jim thank you uh make sure I
get your names in there
uh thank you all for coming and asking
questions I had a really great time
there were some really good ones in here
uh I got to see some
conversations happening some debates
happening in the in the live chat which
was great uh
but on that note um
I I like I like doing these live streams
these are fun
I will try and you know mix in a couple
of these a year I think it's probably
good I don't want to like over overdo it
but uh but yeah so thank you all for
coming and
I'll see you in the comments